então pára de respirar ea foto eu vou
tirar
depois do edson de genes no instagram eu
vou posta logo de manhã já tira uma foto
olha só quem tudo meu carro saindo de
casa uma foto do céu
olha que beleza da fé meu cabelo globo
[Música]
tirei fotos em que a verdade foi de pó
óleo do poço estaria só pra você ver eu
fui no shopping não chame você mas você
já descobriu dúbio a foto que eu postei
com as amigas no estadão
a minha de hashtag estaria tão pára de
respirar
a foto eu vou tirar e depois uma edição
eu vou postar no instagram
[Música]
vou postar lá no instagram
olha só que lindo esse cachorro eu posso
você curte porque tá com dó tiro foto de
lado na frente do espelho porque é de lá
do meu peito fica maior
olha o meu pé adivinha aonde
somando o carro parece mais afetada do
que já sou meu deus não pensei que não
estraga o que é que eu vou fazer já fez
no segue que eu tenho de volta
[Música]
um grupo distinto foto minha bem itália
então pára de respirar fato eu vou tirar
depois coloque um fio proposta lá no
instagram
ah
é proposta lá no instagram
a proposta lá no instagram
essa foto não posta carai o be se
desligou iphae como é que eu vou ficar
apostado meu chip da tim
eu preciso de banks pra mim como é que
eu vou postar
antes da grand am
esse asfalto com lindo no instagram
[Música]
então um fingindo você vai ficar ea foto
eu vou tirar fazer uma edson poética
posta lá no instagram
[Música]
é
é a posta lá no instagram
[Música]
o costa anuncia grande
é a proposta lá no instagram
é a aposta lá no instagram
[Música]